hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the lukini gambit
which is an extremely
fun opening that's filled with tons of
traps so it starts out with e4 e5
and then f3 knight c6 bishop to c4 the
pretty common italian game
bishop here to c5 and the most common
move for white is to play pawn c3
preparing for pawn to d4
there's only three moves that are tied
for a second we have the evans gambit
which is pawn to b4 we have castling on
the king side and lastly we have pawn to
d3 in the leukemia game it comes from
this variation where white plays pawn to
d3 so if you are playing
this variation right here bishop here to
c5 the geocopiano it's always good to
understand how you're going to respond
because your opponent does have lots of
options but if they play pawn to d3 we
have the leukemia game and that is pawn
to f
five now there's a few variations that
we are going to look at the first one is
knight to
g5 you can see uh that this is preparing
for the knight coming down to f7 forking
this rook here and the queen the bishop
here on c4 is doing a good job of
attacking the square here on f7 so
that's going to be the most common line
this knight's also protected by the
bishop here on c1 so it just makes
logical sense we all we also will look
at if the bishop takes here on at ga we
will also look at if white just decides
to castle on
the king side so let's go and get into
it and start with our first variation
the first version we're going to look at
is knight to g5 which makes a ton of
sense this knight is protected by the
bishop here on c1 it can prepare to come
down to f7 attack the queen and this
rook here on
h8 but we're going to play pawn to f4
and there's two main reasons one it
blocks off the dark square bishop from
getting involved into the game and also
we want to play d5 at some point in a
few variations and that opens up for the
light square bishop to not only get past
the d-pawn as well as our f pawn right
here so f4 is a very very important move
in this variation now they played knight
two f seven and then we play queen two
h4 and this is the first trap because
hey yeah okay you're attacking our queen
and our rook sure we have to move our
queen
and now you can just take our rook but
then we actually win the game queen
takes here on f2 and this is gonna be
checkmate so they may recognize that
it's a bad move they're gonna lose if
they take our rook right here they could
castle on the king side since we're
attacking with our queen there bishop on
f2 they could say hey let's castle we
have king of protection this rook here
on f1 is protecting the pawn so now they
may actually feel pretty safe after we
play the move knight to f6 that they can
go ahead and take the rook here on h8
this is another trap because this is
going to lose we played knight to g4 and
this is threatening again this pawn here
on h2 for checkmate really the only good
option they have is to play h3
but then we could just play knight takes
here on f2 after the rook takes we're
going to take here with our queen
and after they play king 2 h1 then we
play the move pawn to
f3 and they don't have a lot of good
options if they take with their queen
here okay well that's going to be
checkmate so that's not a really good
option their other option is to just
take with their pawn here
but then we play the move pawn to
d5
this opens up for the light square
bishop can come up here take the pawn
here on
h3 this is going to be very very bad for
white
you can see there's just not a lot of
great options the white has black also
has the option of getting his knight up
here to
d4 if it wants to and then can later
come up here to e2 depending on where
white goes but all in all this is going
to be extremely good for black if white
falls into that trap
okay so we come back a few moves after
the castle on the king side we played
knight to f6 they don't have to fall for
the trap here on h8 and that's
completely fine they could also try to
blow up the center of the board and one
move to do that is d4 this does attack
this bishop here on c5 putting a lot of
pressure on the king side so they could
just decide hey let's not allow this
let's go ahead and try to stop this
we're still going to play
knight 2
g4 and it is slightly different after
they play pawn 2 h3
but not too much because we're still
going to play knight takes here on f2
they can't take with their king it's
protected by the queen after the rook
takes here on f2 then we play bishop
takes on d4
and this rook is being pinned down and
so you can see
that they're kind of in the same spot
even though they thought they were
protecting the middle of the board it's
not going to end well for them so
another trap they can fall into by
trying to feel like they're controlling
the center of the board so that's all
what happens if they castle on the king
side not a lot of great options
for them now a better option for them in
this position
is to play pawn to g3 we're going to
play queen to
h3
and now let's go ahead and take a look
at the trap again they may decide okay
well
yeah you don't even have your knight
here on f6 so things should be good i
don't really see a way uh your queen's
not attacking this square here on f2 so
it should be
clear for takeoff let's go ahead and
take this rook here on h8 but now we
play the move pawn to
d5 remember we talked earlier about
moving the f pawn as well as the d-pawn
to prepare for the light square bishop
to get involved into the game now they
could take because yeah why not hey this
is a
outpost here for the bishop
free pawn
but we have the move bishop here to g4
pretty much trapping
this queen here on d1 we'll look at both
options they could play both f3 here
they could also play queen to d2 here
just to give you an idea of how they may
actually respond let's look at f3 first
from here we're gonna go and take the
pawn on
g3 which looks a little odd but that's
exactly how we are going to
continue here uh and then sure go ahead
and take our bishop here on a g4 then
we're going to play g2 now this is
extremely important because the pawn can
take this rook here on h1 and promote to
a queen
can also do the same thing if it comes
here to f1 which would be even worse
because then that new queen is protected
by the queen but if it comes here to
g1 you can see that the bishop can just
take here on g1
so white doesn't have a lot of good
options now they could stall you know
they could just take here on c6 then we
take here it's just delaying the
inevitable they play rook to g1 we're
gonna take with our bishop here maybe
queen two d2 just trying to get another
piece to help with the defense here this
knight here on h8 is not doing anything
the rookier on a1 is not doing anything
the knight here on b1 bishop here on c1
not doing anything and chess is all
about the amount of material you have
involved in the attack so the fact that
we gave a rook up here on h8 it doesn't
really matter because we have so much
material attacking our opponent so now
we can take here on h2
yeah sure maybe they're trying to get
their queen involved into the game and
also this pawn here on g4 really stopped
their queen from getting involved into
the game so when we gave up our bishop
earlier in this position right here
after we took here on g3 and they took
it really all this pawn is doing is
stopping that queen from going anywhere
in the game so after queen two e3 well
we don't want to exchange off right away
let's go ahead and take material right
here maybe king 2 d2
and then we promote to a queen and you
can see this is going to be
good game black is going to win this so
that's what happens if they play pawn to
f3 that's definitely one option they
have if they want to hold on to the
queen the other option is just queen to
d2
from here we can play
knight to d4 and this is threatening a
ton of options one is just knight two f3
that's check and also forking the queen
here on
uh d2
so they could decide now okay let's just
go ahead and attack the king uh because
maybe you're always looking at this and
saying like hey the knights here on h8
it could do something it's actually
protecting the square here on f7 for the
bishop to come to
but it doesn't really matter because
black can just play king to d8 and that
threat is stopped okay so if they play
pawn to c3 and yes white has some
options but just give you an idea of the
threat level that black has
we don't even have to play here knight
to f3 first instead we can start to
threaten mate here with queen to
g2
preparing to take here on h1 and then
now maybe rook two f1 and then knight
two
f3 for the check and the fork here on
queen to d2 so it's really a matter how
they want to fall for the trap there's
just so many options we have to strike
our opponent and make things difficult
for them so that's what happens
if they try the variation where they
just play g3
instead of castling on the king side
after we move our pawn to f4 they don't
have to play knight to f7 they could
actually play bishop here to f7 and just
say hey this
bishop is protected by the knight so
let's do something here but we're just
going to play king 2f8
and i think the best move from white is
just to play pawn two h4 but then we can
kick the knight away and it would be a
huge mistake
if they just move their knight back
doesn't really matter where they could
move it to because then we just have a
free piece right here
so that wouldn't be good for white
instead
they probably just want to go ahead and
take right here so the bishop takes and
then after we take here with our pawn on
g5
then they decide to bring their bishop
back here to d5 any other way and
you know either side is going to lose in
that exchange here but then we can take
with our pawn here on h4 and you can see
white has not done anything to develop
the queen inside the board
the king side is wide open so yes we
definitely pushed our f pawn up the
board and our king is somewhat exposed
but they don't have a ton of material
attacking us and we're starting to push
up on the king side of the board we can
put a lot of pressure on them now let's
say they play king to uh g4 can't come
to h5 obviously because of our rook so
maybe they come here and try to be
pretty aggressive with their queen but
then we just play pawn to d6 solidifier
pawn chain opening up for a light square
bishop to attack the queen
it's not going to go well they could
even just try to push the queen down
even more to try a
trap of their own and just play queen to
f7 we're not going to fall for that
because we're masters at the leukemia
gambit we play queen to e7 stopping that
threat and they just don't have anything
else
to do
the other option they could
look at is after the pawn takes here on
h5
they could even play c3
knowing that
they want to get their queen out on the
queen side of the board and not the
queen the king side because not doing
too much but then we just play queen 2
g5 attacking this pawn here on g2
very difficult them to hold on to this
position maybe queen to f3 uh trying to
stop this uh but then pawn to d6
preparing to get the bishop here to a g4
just not a lot of good things going for
white so that is what happens
if your opponent is going to be playing
the most common move which i think and
that is
the knight 2
g5
the next variation we are going to look
at is if the bishop takes here on g8 i
don't think this is very common but i do
want to give some other iterations in
case your opponent does not go with what
we think they will
do now we are going to take their bishop
here so sure yeah if you want to
exchange your bishop for our
knight that's completely fine they could
now play knight to g5 which makes a ton
of sense now the best move really
is to play g6 in this position setting a
trap because maybe they look at this and
say wow that pawn there is free to take
but then we can play the move queen to
h4
and this is almost forcing for us to
take this knight here on h7 because this
is checkmate if they try to hold on to
this knight which they can't really
but the threat is the queen takes here
on f2 checkmate and so they are going to
lose this knight here
on h7 so instead they should not take
that
but another option you have and this is
just the beauty of this opening is
you have so many different options and
your opponent can really fall into tons
of traps regardless of where you go
another option you have is queen 2f6 and
this could bait them to get their queen
out involved into the game queen two h5
check we're pretty much forced to play
g6 here
attacking the queen so the queen really
has to move here and they may think that
they can take this pawn here on h7 but
very similar to the knight if you come
down here this is a poison pond you
can't just take that pawn because we're
going to come and take something as well
we're going to play rook 2h8 and the
queen is going to fall there's no way
for them to hold on to it so that's
what's going to happen if they play
bishop takes here on
g8 and one variation that you could see
another variation is castling on the
king's side i think this probably the
safest of the plays from white we're
just going to play knight to f6
you could try just to exchange material
right here but i think after you do this
you're pretty much forced to play knight
to
f6 and i just don't think it's as good
because now they have the move knight to
g5 and it's pretty annoying to deal with
i think in this position instead
i think it's much better if we don't
take that material and instead played
knight to f6 here
and now
if they played knight to g5
we can play
queen to e7
and now if they come down here with
their knights because they may say okay
this is protected so i'm going to attack
this this rook here well we could just
play rook to f8 and you can see they
really haven't
made any ground up and this is not going
to be good for them so you've pretty
much stopped their threats of actually
coming down to f7
and this is going to be
just all fine for
black
so that is an overview of the leukemia
gambit hopefully you guys have a better
idea of how you should be playing or
potentially should be playing after they
play the move pawn to d3 if you ever run
into this have the opportunity to play
it i highly recommend it thank you guys
so much for watching as always if you
have
other videos you would like to see let
me know in the comments below someone
let me know the other day they want to
see this video so i made it so just want
everyone to know i do read the comments
and i do try to make all the videos that
you request so let me know in the
comments below what you thought of this
video if there's anything else but thank
you guys so much for watching i'll see
you guys in the next one
you